Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishist be the annihilation of the Jews. As soon as I have the power to do so, I will have gallows built in rows at the Marienplatz in Munich, for example, as many as traffic allows. Then the Jews will be hanged indiscriminately and they will remain hanging until they stink. They will hang there as long as the principles of hygiene permit. As soon as they have been untied, the next batch will be strung up and so on down the line until the last Jew in Munich has been exterminated. Other cities will follow suit precisely in this fashion until all Germany
感谢您收听《历史就是如此》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishist。例如，将是犹太人的灭绝。一旦我有权这样做，我就会在慕尼黑的玛利亚广场竖起一排排绞刑架，比如，在交通允许的范围内尽可能多地竖起。然后，犹太人将被不分青红皂白地绞死，他们将一直悬挂在那里，直到发臭。只要卫生原则允许，他们就会一直挂在那里。一旦他们被解下，下一批就会被吊上去，以此类推，直到慕尼黑的最后一个犹太人被消灭。其他城市也将完全照此办理，直到整个德国
has been completely cleansed of Jews. That was Adolf Hitler talking to the journalist and retired army officer Josef Hell in 1922. And Dominic Hell, I mean, that's a very appropriate name, isn't it? It is. And 1922, Tom. So that is before the Beer Hall Putsch. It's before most people outside Germany have ever heard of Adolf Hitler. Even at that stage, he is talking of Germany's Jews again and again as a virus, as a plague, as a mortal threat to the health of the nation. And historians and people generally argue a lot about when the Nazis began the march towards the final solution. But I think there's no doubt that it was there implicitly or here explicitly in Hitler's rhetoric from the very beginning. Don't you agree?
已被彻底清除犹太人。那是阿道夫·希特勒在1922年与记者兼退役军官约瑟夫·赫尔的谈话。多米尼克·赫尔，我的意思是，这是一个非常贴切的名字，不是吗？确实如此。而且是1922年，汤姆。所以那是在啤酒馆政变之前。那是在德国以外的大多数人听说阿道夫·希特勒之前。即使在那个阶段，他也一次又一次地将德国的犹太人称为病毒、瘟疫，是国家健康的致命威胁。历史学家和人们通常会对纳粹何时开始走向“最终解决方案”争论不休。但我认为毫无疑问，希特勒从一开始的言论中就隐含或明确地表达了这一点。你不同意吗？
I do. And in the previous episode, we talked about the idealism of Nazi racism, which might seem a kind of oxymoron. But I think in that passage, it's very evident that hatred fuses with idealism. It's a terrifying, terrifying sense of what is to come, isn't it? In the last episode, you talked a lot about why the Nazis, how the Nazis constructed this kind of moral universe in which they were the forces of light. They were on the side of the angels fighting for the health of their race in a world defined by struggle and by competition.
我同意。在上一集中，我们谈到了纳粹种族主义的理想主义，这似乎是一种矛盾修辞。但我认为在那段话中，很明显仇恨与理想主义融合在了一起。这是一种对未来即将发生之事的极其恐怖的感觉，不是吗？在上一集中，你谈了很多关于纳粹为何以及如何构建这种道德宇宙，使他们成为光明力量。他们站在天使一边，在一个由斗争和竞争定义的世界中为种族的健康而战。
And there are all kinds of groups that they see as threats. So you mentioned gay men, the Roma and Sinti gypsy peoples, or people who are mentally ill, for example. And beyond the borders of Germany, the Slavs in particular. Exactly. But the Jews are different because the Jews are not just another minority. They're not just another burden on the race.
他们将各种群体视为威胁。所以你提到了男同性恋者、罗姆人和辛提吉普赛人，或者例如精神病患者。在德国边境之外，特别是斯拉夫人。没错。但犹太人是不同的，因为犹太人不仅仅是另一个少数群体。他们不仅仅是种族的另一个负担。
To the Nazis, as we described last time, they represent the sort of satanic forces of degeneracy in the world. And all world history is moving towards a gigantic apocalyptic kind of cosmic confrontation in their minds between the Aryans, the Nordic races, and between the Jews. And we talked last time as well, didn't we, about the legacy of the Great War and a sense of sort of urgency and crisis and victimhood, I suppose. And I think Hitler and the Nazis believe from the very beginning, from the moment they take power at the beginning of 1933, that there can be no successful Germany without a final confrontation with the Jews. And if they don't win it, then Germany is completely and utterly finished. And again, it's that strange fusion that we've talked about throughout the series of the supposedly rational, objective, scientific, and the atavistic, the millenarian, the apocalyptic. Because we've talked about how, in the previous episode, how the Nazis interpret
对纳粹来说，正如我们上次所描述的那样，他们代表了世界上那种堕落的撒旦力量。在他们的心目中，所有的世界历史都在走向一场巨大的、启示录式的宇宙对抗，即雅利安人、北欧种族与犹太人之间的对抗。我们上次也谈到了，不是吗？关于大战的遗产以及某种紧迫感、危机感和受害者心态。我认为希特勒和纳粹从一开始，从1933年初他们掌权的那一刻起，就相信如果没有与犹太人的最终对抗，德国就不可能成功。如果他们不赢，那么德国就彻底完蛋了。再一次，这是我们在整个系列中谈到的那种奇怪的融合，即所谓的理性、客观、科学与返祖、千禧年主义、启示录主义的融合。因为我们谈到了，在上一集中，纳粹如何解释
Christianity as an expression of the Jewish spirit and want to purge themselves of it. But in fact, this language of apocalyptic confrontation, this idea of a thousand-year reign, is being drawn from that biblical heritage. It's one of the examples of the way in which even the Nazis cannot purge themselves of that biblical heritage. It's one of the examples of the way in which even the Nazis cannot purge themselves of that Christian heritage. And I think that when you use the word satanic, again, you're right. The Nazis are casting the Jews simultaneously as a bacillus and as a satanic force. And there are kind of different shades of emphasis. Sometimes they will emphasize the fact that they are kind of cool rational scientists purging themselves of a disease and other times as in that opening statement by hitler they indulge themselves in
基督教是犹太精神的表现，并希望将其清除。但事实上，这种启示录式对抗的语言，这种千年帝国的思想，正是从那种圣经遗产中汲取的。这是纳粹甚至无法摆脱那种圣经遗产的方式的例子之一。这是纳粹甚至无法摆脱那种基督教遗产的方式的例子之一。我认为当你使用“撒旦”这个词时，你又说对了。纳粹同时将犹太人描绘成一种杆菌和一种撒旦力量。强调的重点有不同的侧重。有时他们会强调他们是某种冷静的理性科学家，正在清除一种疾病；而另一些时候，正如希特勒的那段开场白，他们沉溺于
the rawest expressions of hatred and talking of sort of raw expressions of hatred i think it's important to say the germans are not alone in kind of east central europe in seeing this huge resurgence of anti-semitism between the wars so there's a very anti-semitic party in poland the nationalist index party of roman domovsky there's the arrow cross movement in hungary one of the most violent and horrific of all these groups the iron guard in romania who even the nazis used to say the iron guard are kind of a bit too violent and a bit too sadistic. So anti-Semitism is everywhere in Central Europe in these years. And I think a lot of that is because with the dissolution of empires and the forging of these new nation states, the existence of so many Jewish villages, Jewish communities and so on, is seen by nationalists as a kind of threat to the integrity of the nation.
最原始的仇恨表达。说到那种原始的仇恨表达，我认为很重要的一点是，德国并不是唯一一个在两次世界大战之间看到这种反犹太主义巨大复苏的东中欧国家。所以波兰有一个非常反犹的政党，即罗曼·德莫夫斯基的民族民主党；匈牙利有箭十字运动，这是所有这些群体中最暴力、最可怕的群体之一；罗马尼亚有铁卫团，甚至连纳粹都曾说铁卫团有点太暴力、太虐待狂了。所以这些年来，反犹太主义在整个中欧随处可见。我认为这很大程度上是因为随着帝国的解体和这些新民族国家的建立，如此多的犹太村庄、犹太社区等的存在，被民族主义者视为对国家完整性的一种威胁。
In Germany, it is different. I mean, Richard Evans, in his brilliant book on the Third Reich in Power, he talks about what makes Germany different. Only in Germany, he says, are there strict laws under the Nazis about marriage and sexual relations. Only in Germany are the Jews robbed of their property. Only in Germany does the government itself organize national pogroms. And only in Germany does the state itself become, in the 1930s, the principal vehicle for anti-Semitism. And it's not just that the anti-Semitism is a kind of one policy among many, that anti-Semitism and the elimination of Jewish influence in the life of the nation is the absolute premise for everything else. I mean, that's what makes Germany, I think, unusual.
在德国，情况有所不同。理查德·埃文斯在他关于《第三帝国在权力中》的精彩著作中谈到了是什么让德国与众不同。他说，只有在德国，纳粹才制定了关于婚姻和性关系的严格法律。只有在德国，犹太人才被剥夺了财产。只有在德国，政府本身才组织全国性的大屠杀。而且只有在德国，国家本身在20世纪30年代成为了反犹太主义的主要工具。这不仅仅是反犹太主义是众多政策中的一种，而是反犹太主义和消除犹太人在国家生活中的影响是其他一切的绝对前提。我的意思是，我认为这使得德国与众不同。
And again, Hitler's ultimate ambition is never in doubt. It said in 1919 in a letter, the ultimate goal must be the elimination of the Jews altogether. In 1922, he said in a public speech, there can be no compromise elimination of the Jews altogether. In 1922, he said in a public speech, there can be no compromise. There are only two possibilities, he says, the victory of the Aryans and the victory of the Jews. So when he takes power, you might expect that the first thing he does is to move towards the destruction of Germany's Jews. But actually he doesn't. And one of the interesting things about this story, one of the remarkable things, is how it proceeds by fits and starts. And the reason that so many
再一次，希特勒的最终野心从未受到怀疑。他在1919年的一封信中说，最终目标必须是彻底消灭犹太人。1922年，他在一次公开演讲中说，没有妥协的余地。他说，只有两种可能性，雅利安人的胜利和犹太人的胜利。所以当他掌权时，你可能会认为他做的第一件事就是走向摧毁德国犹太人的道路。但实际上他没有。关于这个故事，有趣的事情之一，非凡的事情之一，就是它是如何断断续续地进行的。而之所以这么多
Jews don't actually flee Germany is partly because he proceeds kind of slowly. So people are able almost to persuade themselves, well, it's stopped now, it can't get worse. Maybe, you know, this is all a phase, all of this kind of thing. And that's one of the chilling things about it. And is that deliberate, do you think? Is it strategic? Does it reflect an anxiety about whether he can take people with him? What do you think the reason for it is? I think that's part of it. I think, as we described in the very first episode of this particular series, Hitler is not completely secure straight away. So he has to work with kind of the national conservative elites and so on.
犹太人实际上并没有逃离德国，部分原因是他的行动比较缓慢。所以人们几乎能够说服自己，好吧，现在停止了，不会再恶化了。也许，你知道，这只是一个阶段，所有这类事情。这是其中令人不寒而栗的事情之一。你认为这是故意的吗？这是战略性的吗？这是否反映了他对能否带着人们一起走的焦虑？你认为原因是什么？我认为这是其中的一部分。我认为，正如我们在本系列的第一集中所描述的那样，希特勒并没有立即完全稳固。所以他必须与某种民族保守派精英等合作。
The Nazis do not have the support when they come in in 1933 of, you know, a vast majority of the German people. Their vote's actually declining. But also, I think it's fair to say, although Hitler has set out the goal and the end points and the priorities, the means for achieving it are as yet unknown. And we'll see in this and the next episode how they talk about the removal of the Jews. It could mean forced immigration. Exactly. It could mean resettlement.
纳粹在1933年上台时并没有得到绝大多数德国人民的支持。他们的选票实际上在下降。但我也认为，公平地说，虽然希特勒已经设定了目标、终点和优先事项，但实现这些目标的手段尚不清楚。我们将在本集和下一集中看到他们如何谈论犹太人的迁移。这可能意味着强迫移民。没错。这可能意味着重新安置。
It could mean kicking Jews out. It could mean forcing them to emigrate. It doesn't necessarily mean, at this stage, murdering them. Although, I mean, that image of Munich being filled with gallows. Yes. And the bodies rotting. I mean... It's a very ominous one.
这可能意味着把犹太人赶走。这可能意味着强迫他们移民。在这个阶段，这并不一定意味着谋杀他们。虽然，我的意思是，慕尼黑挤满绞刑架的那幅画面。是的。还有腐烂的尸体。我的意思是……这是一个非常不祥的画面。
Put it mildly, yes. And there is violence straight away. There has been violence for years. Violence has always been part of the Nazi repertoire. When they come in in the early months of 1933, there is a lot of kind of slightly random... I don't want to say low level, because that makes it sound like I'm dismissing it or underplaying it, but it's sort of often improvised violence, shall we say. So Ian Kershaw in his brilliant biography of Hitler gives the example of the city of Breslau, now Wrocław in Poland.
说得委婉一点，是的。而且暴力从一开始就存在。多年来一直存在暴力。暴力一直是纳粹剧目的一部分。当他们在1933年初进入时，有很多那种稍微随机的……我不想说低水平，因为那听起来好像我在忽视或淡化它，但可以说这通常是即兴的暴力。所以伊恩·克肖在他精彩的希特勒传记中举了布雷斯劳（现波兰弗罗茨瓦夫）市的例子。
And he says there, you know, he talks about a Jewish theatre director, for example, being beaten up in broad daylight, being stripped and whipped in public by stormtroopers, by SA men. He talks about SA men breaking into the houses of Jewish people and nothing being done to punish them. So from the beginning, there is a sort of sense that Germany's Jewish community are kind of fair game and that the legal authorities will not stop you if you want to take the law into your own hands against them and this provokes from the beginning all sorts of criticism abroad particularly in america where is obviously a large and very vocal and influential jewish community so in the end of march 1933 there are reports that the american jewish congress is going to organize a boycott of German goods. Yeah, because people are so shocked by this.
他说，你知道，他谈到了一位犹太戏剧导演，例如，在光天化日之下被殴打，被冲锋队员、SA队员当众剥光衣服并鞭打。他谈到了SA队员闯入犹太人的家中，而没有任何人受到惩罚。所以从一开始，就有一种感觉，即德国的犹太社区是某种“猎物”，如果你想对他们采取私刑，法律当局不会阻止你。这从一开始就引起了国外的各种批评，特别是在美国，那里显然有一个庞大、非常直言不讳且有影响力的犹太社区。所以1933年3月底，有报道称美国犹太人大会将组织抵制德国商品。是的，因为人们对此感到非常震惊。
And then the Nazis organized their own boycott as a kind of reprisal. And this takes place on the 1st of April, 1933. And stormtroopers stand outside Jewish-owned shops. And this is the first, I suppose you would say it's the first really big step. It's the first time the state has backed an explicitly anti-Semitic demonstration, I guess. Because up to that point, as we said in the first episode, the violence of the SA can often be cast by the Nazi regime as nothing really to do with them. They can't control it. The excesses of people they can't control. Exactly. But actually that boycott, and this goes back to your point, Tom, about why Hitler
然后纳粹组织了他们自己的抵制作为一种报复。这发生在1933年4月1日。冲锋队员站在犹太人拥有的商店外。我想这应该是第一个，你会说是第一个真正的大步骤。我想这是国家第一次支持明确的反犹太主义示威。因为在那之前，正如我们在第一集中所说，SA的暴力行为通常可以被纳粹政权描绘成与他们无关。他们无法控制它。他们无法控制的人的过激行为。没错。但实际上那次抵制，这回到了你刚才提到的观点，汤姆，关于为什么希特勒
doesn't, why does Hitler not murder Germany's Jewish population straight away? I mean, one reason, obviously, is it's a large population. So there's between four... Although, I mean, it's only 1%, isn't it? It's only 1%, but that is still, what, 400,000 people? Of course. But just to emphasise, I mean, that's also one of the reasons why this ratcheting effect over the course of the 30s is so effective, is that actually there aren't that many Jews relative to the size of the rest of the population. So they can be isolated and actually pushed out of German life. I mean, that's ultimately what happens.
不，为什么希特勒不立即谋杀德国的犹太人口？我的意思是，一个原因显然是人口众多。所以有四到……虽然，我的意思是，只有1%，不是吗？只有1%，但这仍然是，多少，40万人？当然。但只是为了强调，我的意思是，这也是为什么这种在30年代过程中产生的棘轮效应如此有效的原因之一，是因为实际上相对于其他人口规模，犹太人并不多。所以他们可以被孤立并实际上被挤出德国生活。我的意思是，这最终发生了。
They become invisible quite easily. Exactly. But interestingly, you see, with this boycott at the beginning of April 1933, what happens is that an awful lot of Germans do not take any notice of the boycott whatsoever. The biggest Jewish firms are too economically important, so they're untouched by it. And lots of people just ignore the boycott. And actually, Joseph Goebbels, who is a fanatical anti-Semite, the propaganda minister, we talked about him in the episode we did about Nuremberg and the Nuremberg rallies. Goebbels called off the boycott after a few days because actually it wasn't very successful and it was a bit embarrassing that more Germans, most Germans, like people everywhere, are just going about their daily business. And if the local shop, which is the most convenient shop, happens to be Jewish owned, maybe they're not best pleased about it. But they're still going to shop there anyway, despite the fact that they're being told not to. So they call off the boycott. And Dominic, at that point, German people who are doing this presumably are not worried about the implications for them of being seen to support Jewish businesses. They don't feel that it's a danger to them personally. Not at this stage, I would say, but it will become in the next sort of three or four years. Absolutely. Now, local boycotts do continue. So all the way through the next few years,
他们很容易变得隐形。没错。但有趣的是，你看，随着1933年4月初的这次抵制，发生的事情是，绝大多数德国人根本没有理会这次抵制。最大的犹太公司在经济上太重要了，所以它们没有受到影响。很多人只是无视抵制。实际上，约瑟夫·戈培尔，一个狂热的反犹分子，宣传部长，我们在关于纽伦堡和纽伦堡集会的那一集中谈到过他。戈培尔在几天后取消了抵制，因为实际上它并不成功，而且有点尴尬，因为更多的德国人，大多数德国人，就像各地的人一样，只是在进行他们的日常业务。如果当地的商店，也就是最方便的商店，恰好是犹太人拥有的，也许他们对此并不太高兴。但尽管被告知不要去，他们仍然会去那里购物。所以他们取消了抵制。多米尼克，在那个时候，做这件事的德国人大概并不担心被视为支持犹太企业对他们意味着什么。他们不觉得这对他们个人来说是一种危险。在这个阶段，我会说不是，但在接下来的三四年里会变成这样。绝对是。现在，地方性的抵制确实在继续。所以接下来的几年里，
at a sort of local level, in a given German city or town, the local authorities or the local stormtroopers or Nazi officials, party officials, might organize a boycott or they might organize intimidation, raids on Jewish-owned shops, demonstrations, and so on. And this wouldn't be directed from the top. It would come from below. So Ian Kershaw, in his biography of Hitler, talks again and again about this idea of working towards the Fuhrer. And the way that works is Hitler is a very lazy man. Hitler is not Stalin. Hitler gets up late and he doesn't do his paperwork. What he does is he rhetorically sets the tone
在某种地方层面，在某个德国城市或城镇，地方当局或当地冲锋队员或纳粹官员、党内官员，可能会组织抵制，或者他们可能会组织恐吓、突袭犹太人拥有的商店、示威等等。这不会是由高层指挥的。它会来自底层。所以伊恩·克肖在希特勒的传记中一次又一次地谈到这种“为元首工作”的想法。它的运作方式是希特勒是一个非常懒惰的人。希特勒不是斯大林。希特勒起得很晚，他不处理文书工作。他所做的是在修辞上定下基调
and he sets out the goal. And then people, as it were, further down the hierarchy, they work towards the Fuhrer. They compete in some ways to find the most radical solution to achieve what Hitler wants them to do. And that is the expression of two important ideological principles. The first is that Hitler is the embodiment of the will of the German people.
并设定目标。然后人们，可以说，在等级制度中更靠下的人，他们为元首工作。他们在某种程度上竞争，以找到最激进的解决方案来实现希特勒想要他们做的事情。这是两个重要意识形态原则的表达。第一是希特勒是德国人民意志的化身。
That is why he is the Führer. But also the fact that there is a common German sense of what is correct. So that these spontaneous expressions of anti-Semitism are framed as being a manifestation of this common German sense of identity. Yeah. What you'll see, particularly in rural areas, is that people will take it upon themselves to realise what they imagine to be, correctly, the Führer's ambitions. Richard Evans gives an example in the spring of 1934 in Franconia. So Franconia in the kind of north of Bavaria, Julius Streicher is the local
这就是为什么他是元首。但也有一个事实，即存在一种共同的德国正确感。所以这些自发的反犹太主义表达被塑造成这种共同的德国身份认同的体现。是的。你会看到，特别是在农村地区，人们会自发地去实现他们正确想象中的元首的野心。理查德·埃文斯在1934年春天的弗兰肯地区举了一个例子。所以弗兰肯在巴伐利亚北部，尤利乌斯·施特莱彻是当地的
bigwig, a horrendous man, the guy who edits Gestirme, a man who is the sort of walking embodiment of kind of furious, violent, sort of demonic anti-Semitism. And it gives the example of this town called Gunzenhausen, which had about 5,000 to 6,000 people in it. And in that town, 1,500 of those people, so more than a fifth, turn out for a massive anti-Semitic demonstration at the behest of a local party leader. And then they just go berserk. They
大人物，一个可怕的人，编辑《冲锋报》的家伙，一个作为那种愤怒、暴力、恶魔般的反犹太主义的活生生化身的人。他举了一个叫贡岑豪森的小镇的例子，那里大约有5000到6000人。在那个镇上，这些人中有1500人，也就是超过五分之一，在当地党魁的授意下参加了一场大规模的反犹太主义示威。然后他们就疯狂了。他们
rampage through this little town. They're dragging out Jewish people, ransacking their houses. They drag about 35 people off to the local prison, and one of them is hanged. And this is something that's not been necessarily directed from Berlin, but it's a local Nazi leader taking the initiative and then the local people kind of responding to him. So that fear, if you're Jewish, is omnipresent in 1933-34. And villages start to kind of, and settlement towns start to boast of it, don't they? So a bit like, you know, you'd go into a village in England today and it would be, you know, winner of regional village in bloom contest or something. They boast about it and be very proud of it.
在这个小镇上横冲直撞。他们拖出犹太人，洗劫他们的房子。他们把大约35人拖到当地监狱，其中一人被绞死。这不一定是柏林指挥的，但这是当地纳粹领导人采取主动，然后当地人以某种方式回应他。所以这种恐惧，如果你是犹太人，在1933-34年是无处不在的。村庄开始，定居点城镇开始吹嘘这一点，不是吗？所以有点像，你知道，你今天走进英国的一个村庄，它会是，你知道，区域村庄盛开竞赛的获胜者之类的。他们吹嘘这一点，并为此感到非常自豪。
Yeah, absolutely. So you start getting signs saying you know we have no jews yes you'll see that particularly in 1935 the most common sign is jews not wanted here but you would people would sometimes make jokes they would say our demand for jews has been sufficiently supplied or there would be threats they would say if you're jew, you enter this town at your own risk. Or we often talked about the Nazis as anti-religious, but they would attempt to tap people's religious sensibilities. They would say, the Jew is the son of the devil or something like that. There'll be a whole variety of these signs. And towns, as you say, be like these kind of Britain in bloom signs.
是的，绝对是。所以你开始看到写着“我们没有犹太人”的标语，是的，你会在1935年特别看到这一点，最常见的标语是“犹太人此处不受欢迎”，但人们有时会开玩笑，他们会说“我们对犹太人的需求已得到充分满足”，或者会有威胁，他们会说“如果你是犹太人，进入这个城镇风险自负”。或者我们经常谈论纳粹是反宗教的，但他们会试图利用人们的宗教情感。他们会说，“犹太人是魔鬼的儿子”之类的。会有各种各样的这些标语。而城镇，正如你所说，就像这些“英国盛开”的标语一样。
They would pride themselves on putting up an imaginative sign. From the top, what you actually have at this point is discrimination laws. So Nazi activists have always been pushing for the exclusion of Jews from the economic and kind of institutional life of Germany. And in April 1933, so just a couple of months really, two or three months after Hitler's come to power, there is the law for the restoration of the professional civil service, where Jews, as well as communists and social democrats and so on, are dismissed from the civil service. Also in April, there are laws discriminating against Jews entering the legal profession, so Jews training to become lawyers. Well, there would be, wouldn't there? Because in the previous
他们会以竖起一个富有想象力的标语而自豪。从高层来看，你此时实际上拥有的是歧视性法律。所以纳粹活动家一直推动将犹太人排除在德国的经济和制度生活之外。1933年4月，也就是希特勒上台仅仅两三个月后，就有了《恢复专业公务员制度法》，犹太人以及共产党人和社会民主党人等被从公务员队伍中解雇。同样在4月，还有歧视犹太人进入法律行业的法律，即犹太人培训成为律师。嗯，会有，不是吗？因为在上一集
episode, we talked about how the Nazis cast the legal system in Germany as being Jewish. So if they're going to, as they see it, purge Germany of this Jewish inheritance, you can't have Jews in the legal system. Exactly. And ditto with medicine. So Jewish doctors are excluded from treating non-Jewish patients under the national insurance kind of healthcare scheme. And then the other thing, we'll talk about this later as well, even at this point, there are quotas placed on the number of Jewish school children in schools. So Jews are slowly beginning to be pushed out of the school system.
中，我们谈到了纳粹如何将德国的法律体系描绘成犹太人的。所以如果他们要，正如他们所见，清除德国的这种犹太遗产，你就不能让犹太人进入法律体系。没错。医学也是如此。所以犹太医生被排除在国民健康保险医疗计划之外，不能治疗非犹太病人。然后另一件事，我们稍后也会谈到这一点，即使在这一点上，犹太学童在学校的数量也有配额。所以犹太人正慢慢开始被挤出学校系统。
And this is framed as clearing up space, as easing overcrowding. And again, it's a bit like the measures that are introduced to keep girls out of grammar schools. Right. Yeah. You know, we alluded to that sense in which women relative to men kind of play a role analogous to the role of non-Aryans to Aryans. On which topic, Dominic? Yes. It's non-Aryans, isn't it? And the definition of a Jew is not racially based.
这被塑造成清理空间，缓解过度拥挤。再一次，这有点像为了让女孩远离文法学校而采取的措施。对。是的。你知道，我们提到了那种女性相对于男性扮演的角色类似于非雅利安人相对于雅利安人的角色的感觉。关于这个话题，多米尼克？是的。是非雅利安人，对吧？而犹太人的定义不是基于种族的。
It's based on, at this point, whether you are practicing it. Well, we'll come to this when we come to the Nuremberg Laws after the break. But the problem that the Nazis have, right, is that they believe in races. I mean, we don't believe in races now, but they believed in races then. So they believe there is a kind of biological definition of a Jew. But actually, when they come to it, they find it very difficult to decide who is a Jew and who isn't. Because for example, if one of your parents is Jewish and the other isn't, are you Jewish? If one of your grandparents is Jewish and the rest aren't, are you Jewish? Now, you might not be an observant Jew, but if the Nazis' thinking is correct and
在这一点上，它是基于你是否在实践它。嗯，我们会在休息后谈到纽伦堡法案时谈到这一点。但纳粹面临的问题是，对吧，他们相信种族。我的意思是，我们现在不相信种族，但他们当时相信种族。所以他们相信存在一种犹太人的生物学定义。但实际上，当他们面对它时，他们发现很难决定谁是犹太人，谁不是。因为例如，如果你的父母一方是犹太人，另一方不是，你是犹太人吗？如果你的祖父母一方是犹太人，其余的不是，你是犹太人吗？现在，你可能不是一个虔诚的犹太人，但如果纳粹的想法是正确的，并且
that it's all about the blood and heredity, then you are, in their view, tainted by having one Jewish grandparent, or indeed, would you be tainted by having a great grandparent? So they start to tie themselves in knots about all this. But at this point in 1933, am I right that the definition is a kind of religious one? Yes. Whether you go to synagogue, whether you're observant as a Jew, not whether you are, as the Nazis would frame it, racially Jewish. And part of that is because they know that to widen the definition, A, it includes far more people, hundreds of thousands of people, so it becomes more contentious. But also there's a risk of upsetting, let's say, the army.
这一切都与血统和遗传有关，那么在他们看来，你因为有一个犹太祖父母而被玷污了，或者实际上，你会因为有一个曾祖父母而被玷污吗？所以他们开始在所有这些问题上纠结。但在1933年的这一点上，我说的对吗，定义是一种宗教定义？是的。你是否去犹太教堂，你是否作为一个犹太人虔诚，而不是你是否是，正如纳粹所描绘的那样，种族上的犹太人。部分原因是他们知道扩大定义，A，它包括更多的人，成千上万的人，所以它变得更具争议性。但也有激怒军队的风险。
There have been a lot of Jewish officers or half Jewish officers or a quarter of Jewish officers who have served a great distinction in the Great War. And some of the army commanders may be a little bit anxious about the idea of alienating all of these former veterans. But this doesn't stop the army, does it? Yeah. On the 28th of February, 1934, the Aryan restrictions are introduced to the army. Yeah. And they lose quite a lot of very good soldiers as a result.
有很多犹太军官或半犹太军官或四分之一犹太军官在大战中表现卓越。一些军队指挥官可能对疏远所有这些前退伍军人的想法感到有点焦虑。但这并没有阻止军队，对吧？是的。1934年2月28日，雅利安限制被引入军队。是的。结果他们失去了很多非常优秀的士兵。
They do indeed. As of course, they've lost a lot of good lawyers, good doctors, good civil servants, good teachers. I mean, that is a problem. And also the other problem is that these kind of non-Aryan provisions, this idea that not to be an Aryan is to be inferior. I mean, it's very offensive, say, to the Japanese. And so the German embassy in Tokyo has to try and explain it. It doesn't really work.
他们确实失去了。当然，他们也失去了很多优秀的律师、优秀的医生、优秀的公务员、优秀的教师。我的意思是，那是一个问题。而且另一个问题是，这些非雅利安条款，这种“非雅利安人就是低人一等”的想法。我的意思是，这对日本人来说是非常冒犯的。所以德国驻东京大使馆必须试图解释它。它并没有真正奏效。
So there is a sense that they haven't quite succeeded in pinning down exactly what they mean by a Jew and that it's insufficiently targeted, presumably is hanging over the Nazi apparatus in the early years of their period in power. Absolutely it is. And remember that the Nazis, they're not entirely secure for the first couple of years. I mean, if you go back to that Night of the Long Knives episode, Hitler, for the first two years or so, is very anxious about being challenged either by the army or by sort of conservative business elites, or indeed by elements within his own party, by the stormtroopers and so on. So that perhaps helps to explain why he doesn't move more radically straight away. Because let's
所以有一种感觉，他们还没有完全确定他们所说的犹太人到底是什么意思，而且它在他们掌权的最初几年里，在纳粹机构中悬而未决，大概是目标不够明确。绝对是。请记住，纳粹在最初的几年里并不完全稳固。我的意思是，如果你回到“长刀之夜”那一集，希特勒在最初的两年左右，非常担心受到军队或某种保守商业精英的挑战，或者实际上受到他自己党内成员、冲锋队员等的挑战。所以这也许有助于解释为什么他没有立即采取更激进的行动。因为让我们
imagine you are a Jewish family. In Germany, you've been there for many generations and you're there in 1933 or 1934. Why don't you immediately leave? Well, one reason is you may well say there's anti-Semitism in a lot of our neighbours, in a lot of our neighbouring countries. So the Nazi anti Nazi antisemitism, it's very distressing, but hopefully it's just a phase and it's not something totally out of the ordinary. We'll just have to live with it for a little bit and eventually they'll be gone. Or you might well say, we haven't been dragged off to concentration camps. The people in our town have not conducted a pogrom. My neighbors still talk to me. All of this stuff is terrible,
想象你是一个犹太家庭。在德国，你已经在那里生活了许多代，你在1933年或1934年。为什么你不立即离开？嗯，一个原因是，你很可能会说，我们的许多邻国都有反犹太主义。所以纳粹的反犹太主义，非常令人痛苦，但希望这只是一个阶段，而不是什么完全不寻常的事情。我们只需要忍受它一会儿，最终他们就会消失。或者你很可能会说，我们没有被拖到集中营。我们镇上的人没有进行大屠杀。我的邻居仍然和我说话。所有这些事情都很糟糕，
but we haven't been forcibly sterilised. We haven't been imprisoned. Maybe this is just the Nazis venting their violent rage for a couple of years, and then things will calm down. And actually, you know what? We'll be able to get on with our lives as we always have. And actually, you know what? We'll be able to get on with our lives as we always have. And actually in 1934 or so, let's say, that would not necessarily, if you haven't studied Mein Kampf and all Hitler's speeches, so you don't know what's coming, that's not necessarily a ludicrous thing to think because you might well say, do you know what? After that first wave, after the business about the boycotts, after the first wave of discriminatory legislation, yes, there is a lot of intimidation. Yes, there is a lot of bullying. Yes, Jewish-owned businesses are being put under enormous pressure and they're being hit with big tax bills and they're being kind of alienized.
但我们没有被强迫绝育。我们没有被监禁。也许这只是纳粹发泄他们暴力愤怒的几年，然后事情就会平静下来。而且实际上，你知道吗？我们将能够像往常一样继续我们的生活。而且实际上在1934年左右，让我们说，如果你没有研究过《我的奋斗》和希特勒的所有演讲，所以你不知道接下来会发生什么，那不一定是一个荒谬的想法，因为你很可能会说，你知道吗？在那第一波浪潮之后，在抵制事件之后，在第一波歧视性立法之后，是的，有很多恐吓。是的，有很多欺凌。是的，犹太人拥有的企业正承受着巨大的压力，他们被征收巨额税款，他们正被某种程度上异化。
But you know what? There is a kind of stability. And actually, interestingly, there's a lot of emigration in 1933, something like 30,000 people or 40,000 people. But in 1934, it slows down. Because clearly a lot of Jewish people think, I hate it, but I'm German and I can live with it. So lots of Jews are taking Hitler seriously, but not literally. Yeah. I mean, your instinct would be not to uproot yourself from your home country. Of course. You know, I mean, you risk losing everything.
但你知道吗？有一种稳定性。而且实际上，有趣的是，1933年有大量的移民，大约3万或4万人。但在1934年，它放缓了。因为显然很多犹太人认为，我讨厌它，但我是一个德国人，我可以忍受它。所以很多犹太人正在认真对待希特勒，但不是字面意思。是的。我的意思是，你的本能不会是把你从你的祖国连根拔起。当然。你知道，我的意思是，你冒着失去一切的风险。
You know, which country do you go to? There are immigration restrictions imposed by other countries. And they win, right? The bad guys win if you do that. Because you would say to yourself, I may be not Jewish first and foremost. I mean, I am Jewish, but I am German. This is my country. Yeah, you might have an iron cross right i fought for this country yeah my family have been here for generations why should i leave and as you say i would lose everything so that is why most people stay and i think towards the end of 1934 a lot of german jews think do you know what it could have been worse i mean it's been terrible but it could have been worse and maybe the worst of it is over and the tragedy of course tom is it isn't is that even in the short term, they are completely wrong.
你知道，你去哪个国家？其他国家实施了移民限制。而且他们赢了，对吧？如果你那样做，坏人就赢了。因为你会对自己说，我可能不是首先是犹太人。我的意思是，我是犹太人，但我是一个德国人。这是我的国家。是的，你可能有一枚铁十字勋章，对吧？我为这个国家战斗过，是的，我的家人在这里生活了许多代，我为什么要离开？正如你所说，我会失去一切。所以这就是大多数人留下的原因，我认为到1934年底，很多德国犹太人认为，你知道吗？情况可能会更糟，我的意思是，这很糟糕，但可能会更糟，也许最糟糕的已经过去了。而悲剧当然是，汤姆，它不是，即使在短期内，他们也完全错了。
Okay, well, I think we should take a break there. And when we come back, we will continue this terrible story. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, a splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes,
好吧，我想我们应该在那里休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将继续这个可怕的故事。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐就是如此》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集、
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. And Dominic, we are looking at how the Nazis in power are slowly ratcheting up their targeting and persecution of German Jews. And we left it with the Jewish population in Germany kind of able to think that perhaps they've seen the worst. But you said that obviously they haven't. So what happens next? Well, let's get to 1935 so if you remember our episodes about hitler's road to war the beginning of 1935 he had a huge sort of foreign policy boost because the people of the czar land voted for integration with germany after the czar
以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史就是如此》。多米尼克，我们正在研究纳粹在掌权期间如何缓慢地加强对德国犹太人的针对和迫害。我们离开时，德国的犹太人口似乎能够认为他们可能已经看到了最糟糕的情况。但你说显然他们没有。那么接下来发生了什么？好吧，让我们进入1935年，如果你还记得我们关于希特勒战争之路的剧集，1935年初，他获得了一个巨大的外交政策推动，因为萨尔地区的人民投票支持与德国合并，在萨尔
had been detached from germany and became a kind of league of nations and protectorate basically exploited by the french once hitler's got the czar back there's a kind of League of Nations protectorate, basically exploited by the French. Once Hitler's got the Tsar back, there's a sense of, brilliant, we've had this little coup, we're a bit more secure, popularity assured, now we can take the brakes off a bit. And so in 1935, when you get to the summer of 1935, there is a kind of ratcheting up of tension. Now, part of this, I think, is because the regime is also under economic pressure.
从德国分离并成为一个国际联盟保护国，基本上被法国人剥削之后。一旦希特勒拿回了萨尔，就有一种感觉，太棒了，我们进行了这次小小的政变，我们更安全了一点，人气得到了保证，现在我们可以稍微松开刹车了。所以1935年，当你到达1935年夏天时，紧张局势有一种升级。现在，我认为部分原因是政权也面临经济压力。
We were talking before about how there's this constant business of fats. The fats. And the sort of cues for butter and all this stuff, because of course they're pumping all this money into rearmament.
我们之前谈到过关于脂肪的持续问题。脂肪。还有排队买黄油和所有这些东西，因为当然他们正在把所有这些钱投入到重整军备中。
So there's a discontent among the kind of the low-level Nazi supporters. And the Nazi bigwigs think we need to give them something. And whenever they think that... Throw them fresh meat. Yeah. It's either a foreign policy achievement, or it's more anti-Semitism. In this case, it's more anti-Semitism. And in the summer of 1935,
所以低层纳粹支持者之间存在不满。纳粹大人物认为我们需要给他们一些东西。每当他们认为……扔给他们新鲜的肉。是的。要么是外交政策成就，要么是更多的反犹太主义。在这种情况下，是更多的反犹太主义。在1935年夏天，
two of the most virulent and outspoken anti-Semites in the Nazi party, Joseph Goebbels and Julius Streicher, they start giving these incredibly inflammatory speeches. So Goebbels and Julius Streicher, they start giving these incredibly inflammatory speeches. So Goebbels tells a rally in Berlin in June. The Jews are trying to spread themselves over our streets. Basically, we've taken our eye off the ball with the Jews. They've come back out of their dens and we need to crack down on them again. Streicher in Hamburg, he has this massive rally, tens of thousands of people. He's sort of screaming at the crowd and he says, you know, we will do whatever we want with the Jews in
纳粹党内两个最恶毒、最直言不讳的反犹分子，约瑟夫·戈培尔和尤利乌斯·施特莱彻，他们开始发表这些极其煽动性的演讲。所以戈培尔和尤利乌斯·施特莱彻，他们开始发表这些极其煽动性的演讲。所以戈培尔在6月柏林的一次集会上说。犹太人正试图在我们的街道上蔓延。基本上，我们对犹太人掉以轻心了。他们已经从巢穴里出来了，我们需要再次打击他们。施特莱彻在汉堡，他举行了这次大规模的集会，成千上万的人。他有点对着人群尖叫，他说，你知道，我们将对犹太人做任何我们想做的事
Germany. They're sort of goading people. And this is the way the regime works, that people will give speeches to goad the people below them in the hierarchy. And they then respond with kind of improvised actions at a kind of local level. At this point, you have a resurgence of boycotts. This is actually the point when a lot of those sort of village signs that you talked about were going up in the summer of 1935. And to give you an example of how it will work in different kind of towns and cities, Richard Evans has this list. So he says, you know, Weimar.
德国。他们有点在煽动人们。这就是政权运作的方式，人们会发表演讲来煽动等级制度下的人。然后他们以某种地方层面的即兴行动作为回应。在这一点上，你有了抵制的复苏。这实际上是你谈到的许多村庄标语在1935年夏天竖起的时候。为了给你一个关于它如何在不同城镇和城市运作的例子，理查德·埃文斯有这个清单。所以他说，你知道，魏玛。
In Weimar, Jews are banned from going to the cinema. In Magdeburg, all the trams have signs that say, Jews not wanted on the tram. In Stralsund, which is on the Baltic, the inns and restaurants in this town, which is a kind of holiday resort, all say, we're closing our doors to Jewish customers, no Jewish customers. And there's a sort of real sense of an incipient pogrom, actually, in the summer of 1935. How do people know that people are Jewish? So if you're turning up to this restaurant and you say, well, I'm not Jewish, how is this tested? This is the interesting thing, isn't it, Tom?
在魏玛，犹太人被禁止去电影院。在马格德堡，所有的电车都有写着“电车上不欢迎犹太人”的标语。在施特拉尔松德，它在波罗的海，这个城镇的旅馆和餐馆，这是一个度假胜地，都说，我们对犹太顾客关门，没有犹太顾客。在1935年夏天，实际上有一种即将发生大屠杀的真实感觉。人们怎么知道人们是犹太人？所以如果你出现在这家餐馆，你说，嗯，我不是犹太人，这怎么测试？这是有趣的事情，不是吗，汤姆？
I mean, it goes back to what we were saying in the first half, and this is an issue that runs through this whole story. Now, there are some Nazis who say, well, get out the calipers. You know, it's all about the shape of the skull and all this sort of business. I mean, obviously, an innkeeper is not going to keep a kind of quack medical kit. And even if he did, it wouldn't. I mean, it's all nonsense anyway.
我的意思是，这回到了我们在上半部分所说的，这是一个贯穿整个故事的问题。现在，有一些纳粹分子说，嗯，拿出卡尺。你知道，这一切都与头骨的形状和所有这类事情有关。我的意思是，显然，旅店老板不会保留某种江湖医生的工具包。即使他保留了，它也不会。我的意思是，无论如何这都是胡说八道。
Exactly. As you say, people don't tend to, I mean, there are some people, the Ostjuden, who are perhaps more, they speak Yiddish, let's say. But there are an awful lot of people who aren't. How do you identify them? I mean, this is the issue. If you're not getting people to wear a badge, which at this point they're not, they don't do that until the war starts. Later on, they get people to rename themselves,
正如你所说，人们往往不会，我的意思是，有些人，东方犹太人，他们可能更多，他们说意第绪语，让我们说。但有很多人不是。你怎么识别他们？我的意思是，这就是问题所在。如果你没有让人佩戴徽章，在这一点上他们没有，他们直到战争开始才这样做。后来，他们让人改名，
don't they? So you have to call yourself Israel or Sarah. But at this point, how do you know? So it comes down to sort of physical prejudice, I suppose, if you happen to know somebody is Jewish. But yeah, as you say, there's that complete ambiguity because, of course, all this is based on nonsensical science, in inverted commas. And actually, that upsurge of violence in 1935, again, there is a bit of a backlash, not necessarily about the antisemitism of it. It's about the sense of disorder and hooliganism. So the sort of middle classes, I mean, the lower middle classes always been the great backbone of the Nazi party. They actually don't really like people rampaging around the streets,
不是吗？所以你必须称自己为以色列或萨拉。但在这一点上，你怎么知道？所以这归结为某种身体偏见，我想，如果你碰巧知道某人是犹太人。但是的，正如你所说，存在那种完全的歧义，因为当然，这一切都基于无意义的科学，加引号。而且实际上，1935年的那次暴力激增，再次出现了一些反弹，不一定是因为它的反犹太主义。而是关于混乱和流氓行为的感觉。所以中产阶级，我的意思是，下中产阶级一直是纳粹党的中坚力量。他们实际上并不真正喜欢人们在街上横冲直撞，
beating people up and ransacking their shops and smashing windows. Because it's reminiscent of the stormtroopers' behaviour in 1933 and 34, and we know where that led. Exactly. Or the street fighting between communists and Nazis before the elections, which the Nazis, they claimed they were going to restore order.
殴打人，洗劫他们的商店，砸碎窗户。因为这让人想起1933年和34年冲锋队员的行为，我们知道那导致了什么。没错。或者选举前共产党人和纳粹分子之间的街头斗殴，纳粹声称他们要恢复秩序。
So there is a big backlash. At the end of August 1935, actually in Breslau, which we talked about before, the city now in Poland, the brown shirts actually beat up by accident the Swedish consul,
所以出现了强烈的反弹。1935年8月底，实际上是在我们之前提到过的布雷斯劳（现在属于波兰的一座城市），冲锋队员竟然意外殴打了瑞典领事，
which provokes great sort of diplomatic protests. I mean, you don't get more Nordic than the Swedish consul. That's true, you don't and actually some nazis then nazi officials having encouraged the violence initially start to make statements saying oh people should calm down a bit the police should try to restore order and hitler is put under pressure so hitler is always torn between radicalism and conservatism. Particularly, he needs business leaders and industrialists and generals and kind of aristocratic or well-heeled people. He needs this. He always
这引发了某种程度上的重大外交抗议。我的意思是，再没有比瑞典领事更“北欧”的人了。确实如此，确实没有。实际上，一些纳粹官员在最初鼓励了暴力行为后，开始发表声明说，哦，人们应该冷静一点，警察应该设法恢复秩序。希特勒承受了压力，因为希特勒总是在激进主义和保守主义之间摇摆不定。特别是，他需要商界领袖、实业家、将军以及那些贵族或富有的人。他需要这些。他总是
needs the support of the elites. It's kind of like having a very violent dog on a leash and you let out the leash and then the dog, I don't know, chews someone up and then you have to kind of haul it back in a bit. That's the process. But gradually over the course of time, that leash gets longer and longer and longer. That's exactly it, Tom. So the way that it works is not the swinging of a pendulum, you know, radicalism and then back to conservatism again. The way that it works is with each outburst of violence and aggression and antisemitism, you move further and further down the line. So you kind of go a bit forward and then you put the brakes on and retreat a little bit.
需要精英阶层的支持。这就像牵着一条非常凶猛的狗，你松开狗链，然后狗，我不知道，咬伤了某人，然后你不得不把它拉回来一点。这就是过程。但随着时间的推移，那条狗链变得越来越长。完全正确，汤姆。所以它的运作方式并不是钟摆式的摆动，你知道，从激进主义又回到保守主义。它的运作方式是，随着每一次暴力、侵略和反犹太主义的爆发，你都会在既定的路线上越走越远。所以你向前推进一点，然后踩下刹车，稍微退后一点。
But at the end of the process, you've always moved further towards your goal. And that's how this works. So in August 1935, the 8th of August, Hitler orders a halt to all the, what he calls the individual actions. So the kind of local pogroms and the local initiatives. Now he doesn't want to disappoint his activists because they don't want the Fuhrer to be putting a brake on things. They want him to encourage them. They think they are working towards him. The conservatives, on the other hand, they say, listen, if you're going to move against the Jews, it has to be legal. There has to be order. There has to be a proper framework for it. There's actually,
但在过程结束时，你总是向着你的目标又迈进了一步。这就是它的运作方式。因此，在1935年8月8日，希特勒下令停止所有他所谓的“个人行动”。也就是那种地方性的屠杀和地方性的倡议。现在，他不想让他的激进分子失望，因为他们不希望元首给事情踩刹车。他们希望他鼓励他们。他们认为他们是在为他工作。另一方面，保守派则说，听着，如果你要针对犹太人采取行动，那必须是合法的。必须有秩序。必须有一个适当的框架。实际上，
in the film about the Wonsay Conference conspiracy with Kenneth Branagh as a hydric, there's a speech, you can see it on YouTube, it's given by Colin Firth, who's playing a lawyer. He gives this great rant in the conference, this is 1942, in which he says, if we lower ourselves to pogroms and violence and smashing windows, then we're just as bad as they are. We should actually proceed in an orderly, serious, methodical way, because that is the only way to win. The banality of evil. Yeah. And there are lots of people in the Nazi high command who believe that, who believe that
在关于万湖会议阴谋的电影中，肯尼斯·布拉纳饰演海德里希，有一段演讲，你可以在YouTube上看到，是由科林·费尔斯饰演的一名律师发表的。他在会议上发表了这段精彩的咆哮，这是1942年，他说，如果我们降低到屠杀、暴力和砸窗户的程度，那么我们就和他们一样糟糕。我们实际上应该以一种有序、严肃、有条不紊的方式进行，因为那是获胜的唯一途径。平庸之恶。是的。纳粹高层中有很多人相信这一点，他们相信
we miss the scale of the Jewish threat if we think it can be solved with punch-ups in the street. But this has always been the way, hasn't it? You have street fights and you win power through the ballot box. It's a combination of the two. It's not either or, it's both. So this is how Hitler resolves this particular dilemma. The party rally, as in the last two years, is going to be held in Nuremberg in 1935. So it's the scene that you described so brilliantly in your episode on that, Tom. The great medieval city hung with swastikas,
如果我们认为犹太人的威胁可以通过街头斗殴来解决，那我们就低估了它的规模。但一直以来都是这样，不是吗？你有街头斗殴，你通过投票箱赢得权力。这是两者的结合。不是非此即彼，而是两者兼有。所以这就是希特勒解决这个特定困境的方式。正如过去两年一样，1935年的党代会将在纽伦堡举行。所以这就是你在那期节目中描述得非常精彩的场景，汤姆。那座挂满纳粹旗帜的中世纪大城市，
great mobs of the Hitler youth and stormtroopers and all this. Parade ground, all that. Exactly. And the Reichstag is going to assemble in Nuremberg on the last day to show the subordination of traditional politics to the Nazi movement. And in this final session of the rally, Hitler gets the Reichstag to pass three new laws. The first
希特勒青年团和冲锋队的庞大暴徒，所有这些。阅兵场，所有这些。完全正确。帝国议会将在最后一天在纽伦堡集会，以展示传统政治对纳粹运动的从属地位。在这次集会的最后会议上，希特勒让帝国议会通过了三项新法律。第一项
is the flag law that decrees that the swastika will be the flag of Germany, replacing the old flag of the German state. So that party, Nazism, and Germany are now formally identified in the flag. And partly this is driven, again, by antisemitism because workers in New York, Jewish workers in New york have torn down a nazi swastika and there'd been a kind of legal argument from the americans that it wasn't a national flag exactly so yeah exactly now the second law is the citizenship law this basically says citizens of the reich have to be people of german or kindred blood and all other people are not citizens they are subjects.
是《国旗法》，该法规定纳粹旗帜将成为德国的国旗，取代德国旧的国旗。因此，党、纳粹主义和德国现在在国旗上正式合二为一。这在一定程度上再次受到反犹太主义的驱动，因为纽约的工人们，纽约的犹太工人们撕毁了一面纳粹旗帜，美国人有一种法律论点，认为它并不是严格意义上的国旗，所以是的，完全正确。现在第二项法律是《公民法》，这基本上规定帝国公民必须是德国人或具有同等血统的人，所有其他人不是公民，而是臣民。
So it basically deprives Jews, German Jews, of their citizenship. This is the Spartan model, that you have the Spartan citizens and then you have the helots, and this is basically where it's heading. Interesting comparison. And then the third thing, which goes back to all the things you were talking about in your episode about Nazi ideology and their obsession with race. The most important is the law to protect German blood. This is introduced by Hermann Goering.
所以它基本上剥夺了犹太人，德国犹太人的公民身份。这是斯巴达模式，你有斯巴达公民，然后你有黑劳士（奴隶），这基本上就是它的发展方向。有趣的比较。然后是第三件事，这回到了你在关于纳粹意识形态和他们对种族的痴迷的那期节目中谈到的所有事情。最重要的是《保护德国血统法》。这是由赫尔曼·戈林提出的。
He's the president of the Reichstag. And I'm just going to read you what Goering says. Goering says, we know that to sin against the blood is to sin against the inheritance of a people. We ourselves, the German people, have had to suffer greatly because of this hereditary sin. We know the final root of all Germany's decomposition, he obviously means his defeat in the Great War, came in the last analysis from these sinners against heredity. So he says it's the duty of Germans and of the Nazis in future to ensure this purity of the race can never again be made sick or filled with rottenness. I mean, it's so interesting because again, you have that fusion of the language of science. So it's about stopping the race from being sick.
他是帝国议会议长。我只想读一下戈林说的话。戈林说，我们知道，亵渎血统就是亵渎一个民族的传承。我们自己，德国人民，因为这种遗传罪孽而遭受了巨大的痛苦。我们知道德国所有衰败的最终根源——他显然是指德国在第一次世界大战中的失败——归根结底来自这些亵渎遗传的人。所以他说，德国人和纳粹未来的职责是确保这种种族纯洁性永远不会再被弄得病态或充满腐朽。我的意思是，这太有趣了，因为你再次看到了科学语言的融合。所以这是关于阻止种族变得病态。
It's medicalized and the language of theology, it's sin. Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. So it's those two things, isn't it? It's the sort of the theological, the inheritance of centuries of Christian antisemitism. Yeah. It is the scientific obsessions of the late 19th century.
它是医学化的，也是神学语言，它是罪孽。是的，绝对是。绝对是。所以是这两件事，不是吗？这是一种神学，几个世纪以来基督教反犹太主义的传承。是的。这是19世纪末的科学痴迷。
And it's the sense of victimhood that comes out of the Great War. We lost because of this issue of tainted blood. We must make sure it never happens again. Because, of course, Goering, Hitler, and all these characters are even at this point thinking they're going to have to have a second world war. And if they don't get rid of the Jews before that, then they will lose again because they will be undermined. I mean, that sense of urgency, I think, underlies this whole business. Yeah. I mean, it's like kind of treatment for cancer. You need to get rid of the cancerous cells. The Nazis would be delighted with that analogy, Tom. I mean, that's exactly the analogy they would use.
还有那种源于第一次世界大战的受害者心态。我们失败是因为这种受污染的血统问题。我们必须确保它永远不会再发生。因为，当然，戈林、希特勒和所有这些角色即使在这一点上也认为他们将不得不进行第二次世界大战。如果他们在战争之前不除掉犹太人，那么他们会再次失败，因为他们会被削弱。我的意思是，那种紧迫感，我认为是这一切的基础。是的。我的意思是，这就像治疗癌症。你需要除掉癌细胞。纳粹会很高兴听到这个类比，汤姆。我的意思是，这正是他们会使用的类比。
They would use a medical analogy, wouldn't they? A medical metaphor. Yeah. So under the law to protect German blood, marriage between Jews and Germans is prohibited. Sexual relations outside marriage between Jews and Germans are outlawed as well. And a sort of bizarre side note to it, Jews are not allowed to employ young German women
他们会使用医学类比，不是吗？一个医学隐喻。是的。所以根据《保护德国血统法》，禁止犹太人和德国人通婚。犹太人和德国人婚外的性关系也被取缔。还有一个奇怪的附注，犹太人不被允许雇佣年轻的德国女性
as servants because it is believed that they will kind of debauch them. But isn't it also because the idea of a Jew giving orders to an Aryan is very offensive? Yes, exactly. But Dominic, also, just to ask you, the implication of this is that people in their most intimate moments are potentially behaving as criminals. Yes. So sexual activity can become criminal.
作为仆人，因为人们认为他们会败坏她们。但难道不是因为犹太人向雅利安人发号施令的想法非常令人反感吗？是的，完全正确。但是多米尼克，也想问你，这意味着人们在最私密的时刻可能表现得像罪犯。是的。所以性活动可能变成犯罪。
Yeah. This is the moment when the SS start to be drawn into the persecution of the Jews, isn't it? Because Himmler has control of the police. The SS you close the door of your family home, you don't keep politics at bay. No. That the politics now comes with you. And that absolutely, there is no private space. There is no personal life. This is an existential apocalyptic struggle and it seeps into every conceivable aspect of human relations.
是的。这就是党卫军开始被卷入对犹太人迫害的时刻，不是吗？因为希姆莱控制着警察。党卫军，你关上家门，你无法将政治拒之门外。不。政治现在随你而来。绝对没有私人空间。没有个人生活。这是一场生存性的世界末日斗争，它渗透到人类关系的每一个可想到的方面。
Absolutely. And judges, doctors, civil servants, local councillors, local council employees, all of these people will be drawn into this great national effort to remove what the Nazis would describe as the taint of Jewish blood from German life. But specifically the SS, because of course we know where the SS targeting of the Jews will ultimately lead. Yes. So just on the Nuremberg laws, in the short term they work exactly as Hitler wanted, which is there's an end to the disorder, the activists are happy, the conservatives are happy, and there's a new status quo. So the process of working towards the Fuhrer, of the radicalisation and then putting on the brakes and then finding a new status quo, that has worked as far as they're concerned.
绝对是。法官、医生、公务员、地方议员、地方议会雇员，所有这些人都会被卷入这场伟大的国家努力中，以消除纳粹所描述的从德国生活中清除犹太血统的污点。但特别是党卫军，因为我们当然知道党卫军对犹太人的针对最终会导致什么。是的。所以关于纽伦堡法案，在短期内它们完全按照希特勒想要的方式运作，即混乱结束了，激进分子很高兴，保守派很高兴，并且出现了一个新的现状。所以，为元首工作、激进化然后踩刹车，最后找到一个新现状的过程，就他们而言是奏效了。
There is, of course, a massive ambiguity that undermines the whole enterprise, because what is a Jew? The law doesn't really define it. They spend enormous amounts of time squabbling. If you're three quarters Jewish, you're Jewish. If you're half Jewish, you're only Jewish. If you're practicing the Jewish faith, which introduces a religious dimension, which kind of shouldn't be there if you're a strict scientific Nazi. Anyway, go on, Tom, you've got a question. Just this issue, again, going back to the SS, it sharpens Himmler's desire, doesn't it,
当然，有一个巨大的模糊性破坏了整个事业，因为什么是犹太人？法律并没有真正定义它。他们花费了大量时间争吵。如果你有四分之三的犹太血统，你就是犹太人。如果你有一半犹太血统，你只是犹太人。如果你信奉犹太教，这引入了一个宗教维度，如果你是一个严格的科学纳粹分子，这本不应该存在。总之，继续吧，汤姆，你有一个问题。只是这个问题，再次回到党卫军，它加剧了希姆莱的欲望，不是吗，
to construct a racial aristocracy because he has this feeling that Jewish blood is kind of everywhere. Yes. And that therefore there is a need to construct an elite who you can absolutely guarantee have nothing to do with, you know, are not corrupted by Jewish blood in any way. And so he demands kind of increasing, you know, you have to go back generations and generations and generations with birth certificates and everything to get into the SS. Yeah, because all of this stuff, the Nuremberg laws, the growing fixations of the SS, all of this is a godsend for the genealogical industry.
去构建一个种族贵族，因为他有一种感觉，犹太血统无处不在。是的。因此，有必要建立一个精英阶层，你可以绝对保证他们与犹太血统没有任何关系，没有被犹太血统以任何方式腐蚀。所以他要求越来越严格，你必须追溯几代、几代、几代的出生证明和一切才能进入党卫军。是的，因为所有这些东西，纽伦堡法案，党卫军日益增长的执念，所有这些对于家谱行业来说都是天赐之物。
Because people are desperately now looking for birth certificates or indeed employing genealogists to show that they're not in fact Jewish. Or that their ancestors were Jewish but maybe weren't practicing Jews or whatever it might be. So there is now this sort of weird obsession with kind of turning up documents from the, you know, the 1800s or the 1700s or something. What this has done now, as you said, they've gone into the home and that the party, the SS, the Gestapo and so on, are now kind of penetrating, as it were, into your bedroom. What this means is that anti-Semitism has seeped into German life more than ever before because all kinds of people are complicit with it now. doctors who are producing certificates and things the people who run you know you run a swimming pool and your local town has banned jews from coming so you're the person who has to turn them away maybe you're not especially anti-semitic yourself you're not even a nazi party member
因为人们现在拼命寻找出生证明，或者确实雇佣家谱学家来证明他们实际上不是犹太人。或者他们的祖先是犹太人，但可能不是信奉犹太教的犹太人，或者其他什么情况。所以现在有一种奇怪的痴迷，就是从1800年代或1700年代之类的文件中翻出文件。正如你所说，现在所做的是，他们已经进入了家庭，党、党卫军、盖世太保等等，现在正在渗透到你的卧室里。这意味着反犹太主义比以往任何时候都更深入地渗透到德国生活中，因为现在各种各样的人都与它同流合污了。医生们在出具证明，还有那些经营游泳池的人，你当地的城镇禁止犹太人进入，所以你是那个必须把他们拒之门外的人，也许你自己并不是特别反犹太，你甚至不是纳粹党员，
but you are becoming complicit and the more complicit that people are the more that people start to believe it so there's a brilliant source during all this period of the letters sent by Social Democratic Party agents to their kind of, you know, they're reporting to their exiled leadership and what's going on. And this is one from Berlin, January 1936. And the Social Democratic agent writes, The campaign against the Jews is not without influence on people's opinions. Very slowly, views are being filtered into it that they used to reject first people read their sturm out of curiosity but in the end something from it sticks and i think there is a sense at the beginning of 1936 or so that things are sticking richard evans is the example of a woman called umita Mashman. We've talked about her a few times. She was a bright young
但你正在变得同流合污，人们越是同流合污，人们就越开始相信它。所以在这个时期，社会民主党特工发给他们流亡领导层的报告信件中有一个极好的来源。这是1936年1月来自柏林的一封信。社会民主党特工写道，针对犹太人的运动并非对人们的观点没有影响。非常缓慢地，他们曾经拒绝的观点正在被过滤进去，起初人们出于好奇阅读《冲锋报》，但最终，其中的一些东西留在了脑海里。我认为在1936年初左右有一种感觉，事情正在扎根。理查德·埃文斯举了一个叫乌米塔·马什曼的女性的例子。我们已经谈过她几次了。她是一个聪明、年轻的
woman who ended up becoming a very keen Nazi and wrote her memoirs very late in life, looking back with great guilt. She talks about how there were Jewish girls in her class at school, but very gradually, those Jewish girls are pushed the margins, and the other girls, they cut off relationships with them. And more and more, she and her classmates just start to believe. They're being told it so often about the Jews being a threat and all this sort of thing, that they come to believe it, and they come to accept the new dispensation. And I think that's how it works for most ordinary Germans. So you have the thing with marriages and people are being denounced. I mean, you have hundreds of denunciations every year, about 420 a year, I think it is.
女性，最终成为了一个非常热心的纳粹分子，并在晚年写下了她的回忆录，带着巨大的内疚回顾过去。她谈到班上有犹太女孩，但非常缓慢地，那些犹太女孩被推到了边缘，其他女孩切断了与她们的关系。越来越多地，她和她的同学们开始相信。他们被如此频繁地告知犹太人是一个威胁以及所有这些事情，以至于他们开始相信，并开始接受新的体制。我认为这就是大多数普通德国人的运作方式。所以你有关于婚姻的事情，人们被举报。我的意思是，你每年有数百起举报，我想大约每年420起。
You will be denounced for marriage or for having a relationship. So it's race defilement, isn't it? Race defilement, exactly. And often people's own families, Tom, will inform upon them because they're so shocked and they don't want to get into trouble. Yeah, exactly. So they're nervous. And people also start to be reported just for socialising with their Jewish fellow citizens, don't they? In a way that wouldn't have happened in 1933, but is happening in 1936, I think. And that's the consequence of this ratcheting up. I mean, it's still not a criminal offence to be kind to a Jewish fellow German. No. But it's kind of seen as expressing insufficient enthusiasm for the new National Socialist dispensation. And therefore you risk being put on a kind of red list. You could be reported for shaking hands with a Jewish neighbour or a Jewish former colleague
你会因为婚姻或有关系而被举报。所以这是种族玷污，不是吗？种族玷污，完全正确。而且通常人们自己的家人，汤姆，会举报他们，因为他们太震惊了，不想惹麻烦。是的，完全正确。所以他们很紧张。人们也开始仅仅因为与犹太同胞交往而被举报，不是吗？以一种1933年不会发生，但在1936年正在发生的方式，我想。这就是这种升级的后果。我的意思是，善待犹太德国同胞仍然不是刑事犯罪。不。但这被视为对新的国家社会主义体制表现出不够热情。因此，你冒着被列入某种“红名单”的风险。你可能会因为与犹太邻居或犹太前同事握手而被举报
or acquaintance in the street. I mean, imagine, Tom, you could be somebody who'd served in the Great War and you bump into a Jewish comrade from the trenches. And you can't shake his hand. You shake his hand and the next thing you know, you've been reported to the local authorities. Now, if you explained this to the local officials, the chances are that if they hold you in reasonably high regard, they would say, you shouldn't have done it.
或在街上遇到熟人。我的意思是，想象一下，汤姆，你可能是一个在第一次世界大战中服役过的人，你碰巧遇到了战壕里的犹太战友。你不能握他的手。你握了他的手，下一件事就是你被举报给了地方当局。现在，如果你向地方官员解释这一点，如果他们对你评价还算高，他们很可能会说，你不应该这样做。
We understand why you did it. Don't do it again. You know, that kind of thing. Yeah. It's not like you're going to be executed or something, but there is a climate of intimidation and there's a definite sense that Germany's Jewish population, because they are being squeezed out of the professions and of economic life and of, you and of the sort of public sphere, the swimming pools and the restaurants at a sort of local level, that they are being pushed to the margins, isolated,
我们理解你为什么这样做。不要再这样做了。你知道，那种事情。是的。这不像你会因为某种原因被处决，但存在一种恐吓氛围，并且有一种明确的感觉，即德国的犹太人口，因为他们正在被挤出职业和经济生活，以及公共领域，游泳池和餐馆在地方层面，他们正在被推向边缘，孤立，
and perhaps slightly forgotten by their neighbours. I think that's the slightly chilling thing. Is there a kind of generational difference in this? So the older you are, the likely you are to have served, say, if you're a man, to have served with Jewish colleagues in the trenches. Are you therefore less amenable to this kind of propaganda? And the younger you are, the more you're getting it in the education system, you're getting it at school,
也许被他们的邻居稍微遗忘了。我认为这是稍微令人不寒而栗的事情。这中间有一种代际差异吗？所以你越年长，你就越有可能服役过，比如，如果你是一个男人，在战壕里和犹太同事一起服役过。你因此对这种宣传的接受度较低吗？而你越年轻，你在教育系统中得到的就越多，你在学校得到的就越多，
you're getting it in the Hitler Youth or whatever, the more likely you are to imbibe the kind of anti-Semitism. Yeah, I think you're right, Tom. I think your instinct is right. So what's happening in antisemitism. Yeah, I think you're right, Tom. I think your instinct is right. So what's happening in the schools? Well, I think the younger you are, I think that the scary thing about Nazism,
你在希特勒青年团或其他什么地方得到的就越多，你就越有可能吸收这种反犹太主义。是的，我想你是对的，汤姆。我想你的直觉是对的。所以反犹太主义正在发生什么。是的，我想你是对的，汤姆。我想你的直觉是对的。所以学校里正在发生什么？好吧，我想你越年轻，我认为纳粹主义最可怕的事情，
as we've said many times in this series, is how much it appeals to young people and how so many young people are swept up by it. So in the schools, in 1933, there had been about 60,000 Jewish children in German schools. There were quotas, as we said, from 1933 onwards. And every year, more and more people basically leave the school system or are pushed out of the school system.
正如我们在本系列中多次说过的那样，是它对年轻人有多大的吸引力，以及有多少年轻人被它卷入。所以在学校里，1933年，德国学校里大约有60,000名犹太儿童。正如我们所说，从1933年起就有配额。每年，越来越多的人基本上离开了学校系统或被挤出了学校系统。
And it's not just because of the quotas. It is because, terrifyingly, two of the groups where Nazism is most popular are among school teachers and school children. So teachers, we mentioned that before, it's academics and students who lead the book burnings in 1933, and it's teachers who often lead the anti-Semitic bullying in schools. I mean, Richard Evans has some absolutely horrible, horrible details. Any parent will find this.
这不仅仅是因为配额。这是因为，可怕的是，纳粹主义最受欢迎的两个群体是学校教师和在校学生。所以教师，我们之前提到过，是学者和学生领导了1933年的焚书，而通常是教师领导了学校里的反犹太欺凌。我的意思是，理查德·埃文斯有一些绝对可怕、可怕的细节。任何父母都会发现这一点。
I mean, you don't have to be a parent, but I think if you are a parent, you find it even more terrifying. Your children would be made to sit on a special Jewish bench. They would not be allowed to go to certain lessons. They would have to sit there and listen in silence while their teachers told the class that it was the Jews who had betrayed them in the First World War, that Jews were hereditary criminals and traitors and so on. Your children would not be allowed to take part
我的意思是，你不必是父母，但我认为如果你是父母，你会觉得它更可怕。你的孩子会被要求坐在一个特殊的犹太长椅上。他们不被允许参加某些课程。他们必须坐在那里，静静地听着老师告诉全班，是犹太人在第一次世界大战中背叛了他们，犹太人是遗传罪犯和叛徒等等。你的孩子将不被允许参加
in the school play, in the school concert, in these kinds of activities, outings and things like that. Many teachers would humiliate your children and give them deliberately, unfairly bad marks and so on. By 1935, as early as 1935, probably about half, more than half, of Jewish primary school children are no longer going to the schools that other children go to. They're going to improvised Jewish-only schools. So there again, you've got an example of how Jewish Germans are being pushed out, are being ghettoized already. And that, of course, will make it easier for their German Aryan, I hate to use the word Aryan, but let's say non-Jewish, neighbours to forget about them or to turn a blind eye later on when things get really, really nasty. Now, the question I suppose you might say is, why not get out? Because we've talked about that in the first episode.
学校戏剧、学校音乐会、这类活动、郊游等等。许多老师会羞辱你的孩子，并故意给他们不公平的差评等等。到1935年，早在1935年，可能大约有一半，超过一半的犹太小学生不再去其他孩子去的学校了。他们去的是临时的犹太人学校。所以在这里，你又有一个例子，说明犹太德国人是如何被挤出，已经被隔离了。当然，这会让他们的德国雅利安人——我讨厌使用“雅利安人”这个词，但我们说是非犹太人——邻居更容易忘记他们，或者在以后事情变得非常、非常糟糕时视而不见。现在，我想你可能会问的问题是，为什么不离开？因为我们在第一集里谈过那个。
And of course, some people do get out. And by 1935, the SS are kind of actively encouraging this, aren't they? So this is, we've talked about Eichmann. This is where he comes in. So he is recruited as an assistant to an SS officer who's been mandated by Heydrich to encourage emigration. And Eichmann is, I mean, he's meeting with Jewish paramilitary officials from Palestine. He actually goes on an abortive trip to Palestine
当然，有些人确实离开了。到1935年，党卫军正在某种程度上积极鼓励这一点，不是吗？所以这就是，我们谈到了艾希曼。这就是他介入的地方。所以他被招募为一名党卫军军官的助手，该军官受海德里希委托鼓励移民。艾希曼，我的意思是，他正在与来自巴勒斯坦的犹太准军事官员会面。他实际上进行了一次失败的巴勒斯坦之行
to try and kind of facilitate it. So there is a sense, isn't there, that the interests of Jews who want to leave Germany and the SS apparatus that want to see them leave are starting to dovetail. So is there an increase in immigration at this point? Not much. That's the extraordinary thing. That is weird then, isn't it? So the number of immigrants, just to give you a sense, 1933, about 37,000 people. 1934, 23,000. 1935, 21,000. 1936, 25,000. 1937, 23,000. So the biggest group left in 1933, but then it's a fair bit smaller. Why? Well, you're German, as we said in the first half. So it's the same as before.
试图以某种方式促进它。所以有一种感觉，不是吗，想要离开德国的犹太人的利益和想要看到他们离开的党卫军机构开始吻合。那么此时移民人数有增加吗？不多。这就是非同寻常的事情。那很奇怪，不是吗？所以移民人数，给你一个概念，1933年，大约37,000人。1934年，23,000人。1935年，21,000人。1936年，25,000人。1937年，23,000人。所以最大的一批人在1933年离开了，但之后人数相当少。为什么？好吧，你是德国人，正如我们在前半部分所说。所以和以前一样。
Yeah. But at this point, you haven't got a sense that it is actually getting worse. Are you like a frog in a kind of slowly boiling pot of water? Yeah. I think that analogy is probably the right one. That you just think with each new thing, maybe this is the last, you know, we'll put up with it. We put up with so much. And it's defeat to leave. Evans quotes a middle-aged German Jew in 1937. He says, why should I emigrate? What can happen to me? I'm an old soldier. I fought for four years for my fatherland on the Western front. I was an NCO and I was awarded the Iron Cross first class. Why would such a man leave Tom? The very famous example, isn't there, of Victor Klemperer,
是的。但在这一点上，你还没有感觉到它实际上正在变得更糟。你就像一只在慢慢煮沸的水锅里的青蛙吗？是的。我认为那个类比可能是正确的。你只是认为随着每一件新事情的发生，也许这是最后一件，你知道，我们会忍受它。我们忍受了这么多。离开就是失败。埃文斯引用了1937年一位中年德国犹太人的话。他说，我为什么要移民？我能发生什么？我是一名老兵。我为我的祖国在西线战斗了四年。我是一名士官，我被授予了一级铁十字勋章。这样的人为什么要离开，汤姆？有一个非常著名的例子，不是吗，维克多·克莱姆佩尔，
who stays in Germany right the way up to the firebombing of Dresden. I mean, he's an incredible eyewitness to that. And he is Jewish. And so his diaries are an invaluable account of what very, very intelligent, because he's an academic. He's a very, very kind of astute analyst of what is happening. Yeah. And his diaries, for those people who haven't read them, they are an
他一直留在德国，直到德累斯顿被火烧毁。我的意思是，他是那件事的不可思议的目击者。他是犹太人。所以他的日记是对正在发生的事情的非常、非常聪明的——因为他是一名学者——非常、非常敏锐的分析，是一份宝贵的记录。是的。他的日记，对于那些没有读过的人来说，它们是
extraordinary resource and a very, very moving and riveting read. Victor Klemperer, I mean, he again is a war veteran. He's a professor of French at the University of Dresden. He has a terrible time. He's basically kicked out of his job. His books aren't published.
一种非凡的资源，读起来非常、非常感人且引人入胜。维克多·克莱姆佩尔，我的意思是，他再次是一名战争老兵。他是德累斯顿大学的法语教授。他度过了一段可怕的时光。他基本上被踢出了工作岗位。他的书没有出版。
He loses lots of his friends. You books aren't published. He loses lots of his friends. There's some talk, could he go to Palestine? But he despises Zionism, doesn't he? He's not a Zionist. He thinks Zionism is another form of nationalism. And he doesn't like nationalism because he doesn't like the Nazis. And he is isolated. He's depressed. His wife is ill. Obviously, she's not Jewish, his wife A ava but she is crippled by anxiety as well and he just sits there at home writing his history of 18th century french literature but he is determined not to go i mean klempere writes no one can take my germanness away from me uh he says he says my nationalism and my patriotism are gone forever but he can never lose his germaness
他失去了很多朋友。有一些讨论，他能去巴勒斯坦吗？但他鄙视犹太复国主义，不是吗？他不是犹太复国主义者。他认为犹太复国主义是民族主义的另一种形式。他不喜欢民族主义，因为他不喜欢纳粹。他被孤立了。他很沮丧。他的妻子病了。显然，她不是犹太人，他的妻子伊娃，但她也被焦虑所困扰，他只是坐在家里写他的18世纪法国文学史，但他决心不走。我的意思是，克莱姆佩尔写道，没有人能夺走我的德国性，呃，他说，他说我的民族主义和我的爱国主义永远消失了，但他永远无法失去他的德国性
and he never wants to so this is the situation at the end of 1935, beginning of 1936, after the passing of the Nuremberg Laws. And then what happens, Tom, is we have a pause because the Olympics are coming to Germany. And Hitler is very conscious of the PR issue. So actually, extraordinarily, what happens for about the next six to 12 months or so is things actually get a little bit better for Germany's Jews. So the signs come down in public. The signs come down. The more virulent expressions of anti-Semitism are dampened down. There are three people with Jewish ancestry in the German Olympic team, most famously the FENSA, Helena Meyer. When foreign dignitaries arrive in Germany for first the Winter Olympics in Garmisch
而且他永远不想。所以这就是1935年底、1936年初，纽伦堡法案通过后的情况。然后发生的事情，汤姆，是我们有一个停顿，因为奥运会即将来德国。希特勒非常清楚公关问题。所以实际上，非同寻常的是，在接下来的6到12个月左右，德国犹太人的情况实际上变得好了一点。所以公共场所的标志被拆除了。标志被拆除了。更恶毒的反犹太主义表达被抑制了。德国奥运代表队中有三名有犹太血统的人，最著名的是击剑手海伦娜·迈耶。当外国政要来到德国参加首先在加米施举行的冬季奥运会
and then the Summer Olympics in Berlin, all sense of anti-Semitism is kind of downplayed. People leave Germany saying, well, you know what, it's not quite so bad. Die Stürmer is withdrawn from the newsstands in Berlin. And so for a time, Germanist Jews can reasonably say to themselves, thank goodness, the worst is over. We were right not to leave. We can just about get on with our lives. But Dominic, of course, the worst is not over. The worst is very much yet to come and i think we should stop this episode here and in our final episode of this series we will look at what happens in the wake of the olympics moving towards the terrible expression of anti-semitic violence that is
然后是柏林夏季奥运会时，所有的反犹太主义感觉都被淡化了。人们离开德国时说，你知道吗，情况并没有那么糟糕。《冲锋报》在柏林的报摊上被撤下了。所以有一段时间，德国犹太人可以合理地对自己说，谢天谢地，最坏的情况已经过去了。我们没离开是对的。我们可以勉强继续我们的生活。但多米尼克，当然，最坏的情况并没有过去。最坏的情况还在后面，我认为我们应该在这里结束这一集，在本系列的最后一集中，我们将看看奥运会之后发生了什么，走向那场可怕的反犹太暴力表达，即
kristallnacht so we will see you next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to
水晶之夜，所以我们下次见。再见。再见。一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐界的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往
therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
therestisentertainment.com 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。